um hello everybody my name is matt
yankovic um i'm here to talk to you
about the issues that could be
destroying your application performance
that may be caused by the database so a
little bit about me um again matt
yankovic my official title is head of
open source strategy or the haas
at percona i've been around the open
source space for over 15 years
specifically in the database space for
all that time and if you don't know who
percona is we do mysql mongodb and
postgres software services and tooling
so you know we also have a podcast that
i host as well specifically on open
source software
now today's challenge and this is a
challenge for all of us is i'm going to
try and fit as much knowledge as i can
into this small bite-sized chunk and so
there's going to be a lot of detail it
is not going to be
a ton of detailed specifics but i'm
going to give you enough to help make
your application perform better and
ensure that the database is up and
running and give you pointers on where
you can look
now you've probably built many an
application and maybe your application
is beautiful and speedy and fast and it
looks sleek like this formula one car
i'm sure that you know you put a lot of
work and effort into you know making it
look and operate in a positive way but
sometimes you end up with performance
that looks like this is the engine
of course nobody wants a hamster wheel
engine and a lot of times that awesome
application that you have is slowed down
by the database or the infrastructure
that you put in place
and a lot of times it is not just about
the database you've decided to use it's
about how you designed your application
built the database internals as well as
the database that you've chosen and how
you've set it up
now a consistent theme that we're going
to talk about when we talk about
infrastructure and that foundation is
we're going to start with you know who's
managing it and is it managed
okay
this is a question that a lot of people
uh don't know the answer to
as developers uh we tend to
think of the database as one of the last
uh pieces that we want to concentrate on
there's a lot of more interesting code
there's a lot of more interesting
features so the database tends to be
something that
we don't want to spend a ton of time on
so when you
have a database can you answer who is in
charge of it who's responsible for
making sure that it's working properly
or are you outsourcing it and as we talk
about that infrastructure the words
trust but verify come to mind
and this is an important concept as we
talk about that infrastructure because
the trend right now is a lot of people
are taking their database and they're
trying to run it as a service in the
cloud they're trying to have someone
else help manage it
and the cloud is a great place a
database is a service such as rds or
azure sql google sql or the myriad of
other databases and services that are
out there they provide some excellent
operational management however they are
not perfect and this is something that
is very important because if you have
chosen to run your database in that
infrastructure
there are some things you need to be
aware of
if you don't manage it your performance
is only going to
scale by spending more money
you go to the next instant size you get
a you know more memory more disk more
cpu usage you increase your spend
and this is where that trust but verify
comes in because in the cloud space
it's important to understand that
if you have outsourced or given fully
managed uh you know providers your uh
your database fully managed isn't always
the same thing that you think it is
so for instance most cloud providers
employ a shared responsibility model and
from a database perspective you might be
running your mysql your postgres your
[ __ ] somewhere else but your app needs
to understand that the database is
architected for it it's designed for it
it's configured tune optimized and
troubleshooted
these are all things that are your
responsibility in the cloud so even if
you are using a cloud providers database
as a service you still need to
understand that there are things that
could severely impact the scalability of
your application within the database
itself
now
you might ask
what about some of these new databases
and so one of the things that has come
up quite frequently in recent times
is these new sql databases if you will
um cloud native databases right they are
awesome
they help you scale your systems and
i've seen a lot of people look at issues
with databases of service they've tried
mysql they've tried postgres now they're
looking at these cloud native that can
scale up and down
these provide a lot of opportunities to
solve some of those scalability
challenges however
while they show great promise
you have to understand that they are not
all designed for every workload
many of these require you to change the
workload of your application change how
your application runs or what sort of uh
data you're retrieving in and what
frequency in order to boost performance
if you do a copy and paste from you know
database let's say postgres to a
postgres compatible database uh you know
you're not necessarily going to see a
performance boost at all you might see
degradation depending on that workload
so
trust but verify if you decide to go
down the route of trying some of the new
databases that are out there in order to
solve some of the scalability challenges
you have
similarly you might see
systems like v-tess or situs
that
provide sharding for your systems which
are is also another way to scale and
boost you know the performance
and again
with a sharded workload some queries
some systems some applications some
workload
they're not necessarily going to perform
faster they could actually be worse so
you have to understand that
not every technology that's in the
database ecosystem even if they do say
it's to boost performance will actually
boost it unless you make application
changes
if you do
make application changes or your
workload does match these can be awesome
tools that can really improve
performance sometimes you know multiple
magnitudes of performance improvement so
that's something to keep in mind
now
that being said so you whether you've
chosen to run on the cloud you're
running in a kubernetes environment
you're
running
your databases
on-prem in your own hardware
there are some basic things from a
development perspective if you're in
charge of choosing these and you're
setting up a new application you should
consider
now the first thing about choosing
hardware and instance selection
is
this
if anybody knows what this is this is a
ram yes i'm going to give one of those
little vignettes of you know memory is
good of course it is because from a
database perspective and this is
foundational
the amount of data that you are
selecting and retrieving
is one of the biggest limiters to your
application performance and the more of
that data that is readily available
in its fastest form is going to improve
the performance of your application
uh you know 100 fold
so if you have all of your hot data in
memory in ram it is better than if it's
on a solid-state disk and if you have
all of your data and solid statistics
it's better than rotational memory or
rotational disk
so it is important that you understand
all of your hot data should be able to
fit into memory and all databases are
universal whether you're running [ __ ]
postgres in odb uh or mysql mariadb
any of the new sql
options
the more memory and the more of your hot
data that's in memory the faster
performance you're going to get
and
you know the more data you put into your
database
that means that there is a risk that
it's going to slow it down and that's
why there's a big push on scalability
how do we scale how do we get more out
of our systems
and unfortunately today
we are data hoarders i would challenge
anyone in this room anyone watching
later on
have you ever had a manager who has said
we don't need to keep more data we need
less and the answer is no
in most cases people want to hoard data
just in case and that makes it very
difficult
and if you look at this these two sides
think of this as your database it's
easier to get around the after picture
than the before picture of this uh
hoarders setup because there's less
clutter and the less clutter you have in
your database the better off it is
so keep that in mind the more that fits
in the memory the better the less
clutter in your system
now of course one of the other things
when you're choosing a instance or
hardware
is going to be
what about concurrency what about those
cpus
in most of the time
concurrency matters more than raw speed
in your
cpu selection
so you want more cores as opposed to
more uh
megahertz per second uh and that's going
to be something that uh
is important because as your number of
users grow and the number of queries
grow you want them to run concurrently
so some general rules on hardware
selection and optimizing your system and
making sure you've chosen the right
infrastructure okay make sure all of
your hot data is regularly in memory
um if you do have a lot of
data that you need make sure it's on
faster disk make sure you use guaranteed
i o if it is a
heavy i o system
see if you can get rid of some of that
data or reduce it and make sure that you
know if you're going to have a lot of
concurrent users that you are using more
course now another opportunity to reduce
the database side of things is to put
caching in front of it so if you want to
use redis memcache something like that
that is another option
but really you want to select and use
the smallest amount of data possible
hitting the database and being retrieved
at any one time
now
now that we've kind of talked about the
infrastructure we built this awesome car
and we've kind of made sure that the
engine component is there let's get the
sports car onto the road and if you were
to take that formula one car and put it
on this road the performance would not
be as good as you might think right this
is not a road designed for formula one
sports cars this is an off-road and this
is a design issue if you design the
sports car and this is the road you need
to go on that's a problem and so i want
to talk a little bit about design
because for most applications from a
database perspective
the scale and performance of that
application is heavily dependent on the
design
the design matters most because let's be
honest if you get the hardware wrong
it's generally fairly straightforward to
upgrade to the next level of hardware
it's generally easier to upgrade to uh
you know add additional nodes to a
replica things like that if you need to
redesign the entire application from the
ground up that's a very expensive
prospect
now the number one issue we see
when we're talking about
database performance issues and
scalability issues when we run into
these
is
design issues
and
this is an over and over again problem
and it's really hard to get right
so when you look at this you see
number one things like bad data type
selections right using larger data types
than you need whether you're going to
use an int versus a big versus a numeric
versus something else poor schema design
over reliance and orms many of us might
use sql alchemy you might use uh ruby on
rails
might use hibernate all kinds of
different orms orms are great to
simplify your code but a lot of times
they'll choose the wrong type of access
path for a query they might choose more
data than they need
and you need to understand that just
because something's there to make it
easy doesn't necessarily mean it will
make it
fast
similarly when we get back to that
hardware you design your system you
might over or under engineer the
hardware side and so it's important to
understand how these flow together
now you might be thinking okay
i don't need to worry about schema
because i am schema-less um some of you
might be running mongodb or might be
running other systems that
have flexible schemas i am here to tell
you that schema list does not really
exist it is a marketing
tool okay now
yes there are things that are
designed to be flexible and to make you
not worry about the schema but the truth
is this is really more about do you
structure your data or not and where do
you do the validation for your schema
schema list designs tend to push most of
the logic to the application side where
you need to validate in code which may
be okay for you but that flexibility can
come at a price
and so sometimes the databases
themselves even these schemas databases
need to still manage a validation scheme
behind the scenes and those aren't
always as efficient
so when you employ one of these
unstructured data structures you go
schemas you just kind of throw whatever
into a database you're going to trade
off performance scalability for that use
of flexibility
even in the most advanced databases even
in you know systems that are designed to
be quote unquote schemas this is
something that we see happen quite a bit
because when you start to throw
iteration upon iteration of your schema
and of your json documents
oftentimes how you're selecting the data
out slows down bogs down because there
are things that are there aren't there
indexes don't quite work the same way so
it's important to understand that if you
are going to choose one of these designs
that you're still going to have to think
through that and the more design thought
you put in up front the better off
you're going to
be now that being said i've harped a
little bit on data types
and i want to point out from a data type
perspective why data types matter so
much and i'm going to give you a real
world example here this is something
very easy it's nothing that's you know
groundbreaking but let's say you wanted
to store the string one two three four
five six
now that could be a number or it could
be a string
if you take a look here we've stored it
as a varchar 32 with the utf-8 we've
stored it as a var chart 32 with latin
this is these are all mysql uh for this
example and we've stored it as an int in
a big end you can see that each of these
fields
will take 21 bytes seven bytes four
bytes eight bytes but you see the
difference
right if you were to store this as a
varchar 32 in a utf-8 it's almost two
gigs worth of data whereas the int is
381.
now remember what i said the more hot
data can fit into memory the more
scalable the application and you know
the database is going to be well in this
case if you've got you know 16 gigs of
memory available
uh you know
1 8 is going to be taken by the first
one whereas uh you know a very small
percentage is going to be taken by the
end so
it's about trying to optimize what's
being stored in memory
and that's an important thing
now at one point we worked with a large
social media company if you were to look
at the top five social media companies
in the world it's one of them
um without naming their names
and they were running into scalability
issues uh you know when they were going
through massive growth uh about
eight nine years ago
and they had keyed everything off of
their email address
and you know an email address being you
know something very long it could be up
to 100 characters
this is something that uh for most
people it just makes sense
um you know that you know hey
we want to store this and everything
will be keyed off of this now in mysql
which is what they happen to use
the primary key is also stored in every
other index that you build so that means
that that hundred bytes that is being
used for the email is also in every
subsequent index as a lookup
which means that they had 10x the amount
of data they needed to store
now what we ended up doing was
converting their email primary key to a
auto increment so a sequence a number
one two three four five six and we also
put a hash
crc32 hash of the email address and we
made those two combined their primary
key that minute was a maximum of eight
bytes as opposed to the hundred so there
was a 10x improvement not only in
storage but there was a massive almost
20x improvement in performance
because
less data is in memory
less
uh cpu cycles are spent trying to
compare
the uh
varchar values and you know uh it was a
huge win for them
so many of you might use uuids and many
orms you use use uuids internally so a
32 you know by representative uh of a
uni uh unique uh id
that can actually kill performance and
so that's something to keep in mind
now i mentioned that you know mysql
the indexes all contain the primary key
indexes are probably your number one
friend when it comes to troubleshooting
queries and query performance
and so you've probably heard this
numerous times all over the world so i'm
not going to go too much into this but i
want to leave you with a couple of
things too much of a good thing can be a
bad thing
i've seen it many many times where
people will index almost every column
that is not good okay you should limit
the number of indexes because every
index you add adds additional overhead
to maintain that index
so every column doesn't need an index
just the most frequently queried or
filtered columns do every database has
their own set of indexes and there's
different use cases for individual
indexes now we've done talks before i'm
happy to point you to some resources if
you're interested in which individual
indexes do what
we do have that
detail there
now i want to also say
use what you need okay
don't keep everything just in case
archive what you don't need and be
mindful that a lot of orms and a lot of
database applications do a select star
to select all the data from the uh
systems all at once this is something
that can kill performance okay
i'm sorry to interrupt you we've hit uh
the time limit for talk so we should
slowly move uh to the
question uh answers and questions so
please uh finish the idea and slowly
move to the okay i think i only have
like two more slides so
one minute um so be mindful of that
select star um and i do have some
uh configuration options in case you are
interested mysql configuration options
which ones you should uh potentially
look at and postgres configuration
options uh but keep in mind you have to
tune your system for the workload
and um
don't over engineer things if possible
uh you could follow us if you want to
get more on this topic we have a vibrant
youtube channel we also have a blog with
uh you know tons of 15 years worth of
database content all in the open source
space